los residentes de Lima hacen todo lo
posible para refrescarse mientras el
mundo alcanzó un récord de calor por
tercer día consecutivo el miércoles la
temperatura media mundial fue de 17,18
grados Celsius llegando al mismo punto
que el martes el día más caluroso en al
menos 44 años pero no es una sorpresa
para muchos científicos que reiteran que
el cambio climático continuará elevando
los termómetros
continuaremos rompiendo récords mientras
continúa el cambio climático hasta que
las emisiones de gases de efecto
invernadero dejen de acumularse en la
atmósfera
el jueves el servicio climático de la
Unión Europea declaró que el pasado mes
de junio fue el más caluroso jamás
registrado los científicos temen que los
récords vayan a repetirse con la llegada
de El niño un fenómeno natural
desencadenado por cambios en la presión
atmosférica y los vientos que aumentan
las temperaturas en todo el planeta el
niño y su opuesto la niña que rebaja las
temperaturas empiezan en el océano
Pacífico con un patrón que dura entre 2
y 7 años de media el ciclo de la niña
dominó los últimos tres años pero en
junio los científicos confirmaron que el
ciclo del niño está en marcha
los años del niño particularmente cuando
son fenómenos moderados o fuertes
típicamente se convierten en los años
más calurosos de la década Así que este
es el calor del niño el aumento de las
temperaturas de los océanos sumado a los
efectos del cambio climático nos lleva a
este potencial de batir récords de
temperaturas de días meses y años
la última vez que ocurrió un fenómeno
fuerte del niño fue en 2016
y el mundo experimentó su día más
caluroso hasta el momento los
científicos advierten que este Julio
podría llegar a ser el más caluroso
jamás registrado